يتميز اليخت الذي يبلغ طوله 280 قدمًا والذي يبلغ طوله 280 قدمًا ويضم
مسبحًا
يتحول إلى مهبط للطائرات المروحية
ويضم أجنحة رئيسية وكبار الشخصيات لاستيعاب
ما يصل إلى 14 ضيفًا وقد
استولت عليه الحكومة الفرنسية للتو ، وهو
مرتبط بمحطة إيغور الرئيس التنفيذي للروسيا.
روسنيف العملاقة للنفط على الرغم من أن
شركة اليخوت تقول الآن إنه لا يمتلكها
لجلسة الاتحاد الأوروبي التي أقرها الاتحاد الأوروبي في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع ، واصفة إياه بأنه أحد
أكثر مستشاري الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الموثوق بهم والأقرب إلى
الاستيلاء على إجراء منسق
من الدول الغربية مما يجعل الأمر
صعبًا بالنسبة له.  المليارديرات الروس
للعمل والضغط على بوتين ،
هذا ما يهتم به ، وهذا
هو المهم بالنسبة له ، وهذا يساعد
لأن الأوليغارشية تعتني بأموال بوتين
ونريد معاقبة بوتين شخصيًا
ومباشرًا على ما فعله وهذه هي
الطريقة الأكثر مباشرة  القيام بذلك
هدف آخر للعقوبات المنسقة
، يخت السوبر ديلبار الذي
يتم تجديده حاليًا في هامبورغ  ألمانيا
والمملوكة من قبل مغناطيس الهاتف والتعدين
، بها عشرات الكبائن وطاقم مكون من 96
شخصًا يمكن للضيوف السباحة في مسبح بطول 80 قدمًا
بمجرد أن يتم وضع أكبر يخت على الإطلاق على الإطلاق ،
وفقًا لمراجعة
CNN من marinetraffic.com ، تم
الإبلاغ عن اليخوت إلى  أن تكون مملوكة من قبل
الأوليغارشية الروسية المنتشرة في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
كان البعض منهم في طريقهم بالفعل نحو
موانئ أكثر ودية تحسبا
لقمع عالمي ، والمشكلة هي
أن العقوبات قد تم الإعلان عنها
في وقت مبكر ، لذا فمن المحتمل الآن
أنهم جميعًا مشغولون بصفقات هندسية محمومة
يمكن أن يتم فيها تغيير
الملكية في اللحظة التي يتم فيها فرض العقوبات ،
لذا ستكون
لعبة القط والفأر للأسف
، ربما تكون لعبة القط والفأر قد
بدأت بالفعل حتى مع المليارديرات الروس الذين
لا يخضعون لعقوبات
سوبر نوفا المجرة مع رخام فلوريدا الختم
مسرح في الهواء الطلق وحوض سباحة شلال
يقال إن ملكًا لمدير شركة نفط روسية
غادر برشلونة يوم
السبت وعبر منطقة التأمل
على الرغم من أن الملكية
غالبًا ما تكون مخبأة خلف
سجلات معقدة وشركات وهمية ، فإن هذه
اليخوت هي رمز للنقود
والأوليغارشيين الذين قاموا ببنائها في ظل
الكماليات مثل أنظمة الدفاع المضادة للصواريخ
، والأبواب المقاومة للقنابل وغواصة صغيرة
أو صالون تجميل و
مصعد يخت واحد الآن بعيدًا عن متناول
أي سلطات غربية
، تكهنت وسائل الإعلام الألمانية الرشيقة بأن المالك
ليس سوى فلاديمير بوتين نفسه
قبل أسبوعين من غزو
أوكرانيا ، غادر اليخت هامبورغ ألمانيا
وسارع إلى كالينينغراد روسيا حيث
لم يتم تسجيل أي بيانات عن الموقع  منذ ذلك الحين
وبريانا وجون ، لم تكن
اليخوت مجرد يخوت ، فقد فرضت الحكومة الأمريكية عقوبات على
خمس سفن تقول إنها مرتبطة
ببنك روسي ، فهذه ناقلات نفط وشحن ،
وفي إشارة إلى أن بعض
هذه العقوبات قد يكون لها
التأثير المنشود الذي
تقوله الكاتبة كاثرين بيلتون  لقد تحدثت إلى بعض
هؤلاء القلة الذين قالت
إنهم صُدموا للتو ولم أفكر أبدًا في بو  سوف
يذهب القصدير إلى هذا الحد